hi
in this video I will talk about
real-time quantitative PCR real-time
quantitative PCR is one of the most
important technique these days in
biomedical research and also fundamental
research so before going to the
mechanism how real-time PCR works we
should look at what are the utility of
real-time qpcr Milton qpcr could be used
for quantitative gene expression
analysis copy number analysis
differential gene expression analysis
and also variety of diagnostic uses now
real then qpcr could use two different
chemistry's or two different reaction
mechanisms one is a die based method
which utilized cyber cream or one is a
pro based method which use TaqMan probes
in this video i will talk about cyber
bullying based detection mechanism now
cyber green is a done so when it is not
bound to any double-stranded DNA
it won't flourish so in a solution we'll
just have any double-stranded DNA
cyber green would be there but it
doesn't flow us now let's say that the
same cyber green when it is bound with a
double-stranded DNA it will start
fluorescing so this is the whole concept
behind cyber gray now just like a normal
PCR reaction real-time PCR is a normal
PCR reaction but the fundamental
difference is we can monitor the
progress in real time we can understand
how the amplification process is
happening so the first process the first
step of this whole real-time model
officia process is very similar to a PCR
process which is a melting in the
melting State the DNA strands would be
melted as the temperature rises to 95
degree centigrade clean strands would be
mailed it into two separate strands
after that in a primer annealing step
there would be a leading of the fragment
and it would amplify it would actually
exchange the primers and in the
extension state there will be another
copy of DNA for
now since cyber green is in the solution
of these reaction mixture so cyber green
can bind to any double-stranded DNA so
you could bind to these double-stranded
DNA and start tracing now after the end
of another cycle there would be more DNA
and there will be more cyber cream
signals so it to PCR has a fluorescent
detector so this fluorescent detector
can dictate the signal coming from these
DNA samples so over cycles there would
be a huge increase in fluorescence so
for fast few cycles the fluorescence
would be below our detection threshold
but after a point the few loose
fluorescence would reach the threshold
and cross the threshold and grow
linearly and after a time point it would
saturate the point where the fluorescent
rise above the base line is known as
cycle threshold or CQ or CT well now
here is a real-time amplification plot
from real-life experiment where you can
see where you can see here two
amplification plots and here is the
fluorescence baseline so for this and
this is that for this particular curve
family of curves are for one gene and
this is for another gene can see for
this gene the amplification is near
about 20 so the cycle threshold is near
about 20 whereas before these gene
clusters the cycle threshold is near
about third so from that you can clearly
understand that this chain is more
abundant that's why it take less time
less cycles to increase the fluorescence
beyond the threshold level but this gene
is pretty less amount that's why it
takes more PCR cycles to detect the
fluorescence coming from these amplified
DNA and here is the quantitative value
that the Machine gives you now for on
which parameters does the DLN PCR
reactions
actually the quality of the real will
that we see a reaction is very for
optimum reaction condition we need to do
good primer designing most an
amplification efficiency of real-time
PCR reaction should be good there will
be there should be less well - well
variations and also the quality of the
RNA and cDNA matters and last but not
the least the my fitting efficiency is
the most important part now how to
understand that whatever amplification
has happened in real name quantitative
PCR is specific or not let's say the lot
of amplifications happened in the PCR
cycle and these and these small products
are known as amplicon now if we increase
the temperature after the amplification
what would happen they would melt and
once they melt the cyber green won't be
attached to the double-stranded DNA and
there would be increase in the
fluorescence levels so you can see here
is the fluorescence level after
amplification but one after
amplification has the temperature rises
so there are points where the
fluorescence level sharply decreases so
these are known as many temperatures
where the amplification melt and if you
do a derivative of this curve you would
get am a little peak so in one single
male Pig means there is one single
product but if you get multiple matrix
that means there could be multiple
different nonspecific products as well
and if you run the gel so you would see
multiple bands coming up but we should
expect that our reaction is giving us a
single product of the desired length
so the length could be checked by
running it into the tail and each time
we run the reaction for the same gene
you should look at the melting
temperature now when there is a
contamination from a genomic DNA or when
there is contribution from other sample
or
many other reason or there could be are
nonspecific amplification there could be
our target amplicon along with that
there could be other applicants so these
would give right rise to several steps
in our middle peak so this kind of made
it big is not okay and it is indicative
of nonspecific amplification if this
kind of milk peak appears then we cannot
use the reaction for further analysis so
now how to get rid of that kind of
nonspecific amplification so you know
all genes all genes are made up of
intron and exam so these part is the
intro now once it forms a pre mRNA
micron is still there but once the mRNA
is processed these introns are spliced
out so if you make a primer which is
spending these boundaries then it would
only amplify from the cDNA pool the
target of it but doesn't amplify the
genomic DNA content from from the
genomic team so from the cDNA when we
make C DNA from this mRNA it won't have
the intro so anything the primer would
pick up would be in the boundary of this
exon exon so it won't be picking up
anything even if there is a genomic DNA
contamination from this way we can
reduce the chance of nonspecific
amplification other possibility of
nonspecific amplification is non optimal
mainly non optimal annealing temperature
of the primer so to mean a gradient PCR
we can first check the proper annealing
temperature of the primer and you can
use that in our reaction to optimize our
reaction properly so in this video I
didn't talk that much about the analysis
of the real-time qPCR data but in the
next video I will put that so if you
like like a video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you
you